On peut assimiler des individus mais pas des peuples,
donc on a 1 individu d'origine africaine,
maghrébine, New waylorion.
Il y a aucun problème avec la simulation,
c'est bien sûr possible,
mais là c'est la question de la quantité de personnes.
La constitution devrait de véritables communautés
parallèles, les diasporales,
suffisamment fortes pour qu'il y ait plus
besoin d'assimulation,
la
simulation qui devient impossible à cause de ce nombre,
alors que avec des réfugiés d'autres pays,
je pense qu'ils sont tellement proches culturellement,
ces problèmes ne vont pas se poser.
Et d'ailleurs le le maire de Perpignan,
Louis Alio, qui est Rassemblement National
à l'um, euh accueilli plusieurs familles euh
ukrainiennes dans sa ville.
Et pourquoi ? Alors
pourquoi
différencier les les plus écraniens des autres ?
Non c'est pas 1 différenciation.
J'veux dire, c'est pas 1 question de de dire, euh,
ces types de personnes ne peuvent pas venir en France,
ne sont pas compatibles avec la France et cetera.
Mais c'est,
disons l'accumulation de décennie d'immigration
d'origine extra européenne
qui a rendu le concept de simulation absolument
impossible à appliquer pour autant de personnes